Nikki Haley has a new ad out identifying
the enemy the villain in her
presidential campaign Nikki Haley fought
America's enemies at the U.N and won
China's dictators want to cover the
world in communist tyranny Nikki Haley
tough as Nails smart as a whip unafraid
to speak the truth communist China won't
just lose
communist China will end up on the ashy
of History
a strong leader for a strong America I
really like Nikki Haley this is a very
bad ad it's a very bad ad because it it
looks like something out of the 80s
there would be virtually no difference
between the ad that Nikki's campaign is
running in 2023 and an ad that any
Republican would be running from the
1960s through the 1980s